hey guys
welcome back to another video by simply
learn
now in this video we're going to learn
about react.js set state method
however to learn the understanding of
this method we'll first look at what
react.js state is
but before we begin if you haven't
subscribed to our channel already
make sure to hit the subscribe button
and the bell icon to never miss an
update
so without further ado let's begin
typically a state is an
object that stores the values of
properties belonging to a component
now these values can change over a
period of time either via user
interactions
or network changes and the state helps
facilitate this functionality
every time the state changes react
re-renders the component to the browser
the state is initialized in the
constructor a state can also store
multiple
properties a method called set state is
used to update the value of the state
object now this function performs a
shallow merge on the new and the
previous state
conventionally a shallow merge ensures
that the previous state values are
overwritten by the new state values
now that we've learned all about state
let's go ahead and build an application
to see the working of state
all right so in my code editor that is
vs code i've created my application say
state
and here in my source folder i have my
app.js file
now here i'm going to get rid of all the
unnecessary
code that i'm not going to be using also
i suggest you go through the react
installation on windows video to help
you get started with
creating your first application so let's
create our class component say
class app extends react
dot component inside i have a render
method
that returns an html tag let's display a
message
welcome let's follow the jsx conventions
and enclose all the html tags within the
div tag
so i say div class name equals
app we also have to import the app.css
file
import app dot css
so we save it and if you look at the
browser we have welcome
now let's beautify our code to do that
let's add some styling
so here in my app.js class component
i say styles equals
and i say font style
and i set it to say bold and i say
color say teal and here in my h1 tag
i say style equals this
dot styles so let me save it and if you
look at the browser now we have welcome
in teal and it's bold
now let's go ahead and create a class
component to understand
state so first i create a folder and i
call it
components and inside this folder i
create
a class component and i call it new comp
dot js and i use the snippet rce
to create the class component to give
you an insight into what we're doing
today
we'll display a message asking the user
to subscribe to simply learn
once the user clicks on the subscribe
button we instruct them to click on the
bell icon
and finally we display a thank you
message now to do all of this we're
going to make use of state and as
mentioned earlier
we initialize the state object in a
constructor
so let's use the snippet r const to
create
a constructor now in the state object we
initialize a property
let's call it message and we display a
message saying
subscribe to simply learn let's save it
and here in our render method let's say
class name
equals app and let's create an h3 tag
and within the tag i display the message
so i say
this dot state dot
message let's save it and now let's
import it in our app.js component
so i'll get rid of export here and here
i say
import new com from components and new
comp
and let's define it here and say
new so we save it and look at the
browser it says
subscribe to simply learn all right
again to make our code look more
presentable let's add in styles
so i'll just copy the same styles that
i've added here
and i paste them here and instead of
bold i make it italic
and i change the color to say
purple and again in my h3 tag i define
style
and initialize it to distort styles so
let me save it
and now if you look at the browser it's
in italic and it's in purple
okay so moving ahead let's create a
button that reads subscribe
and once the user clicks on it the
button should read subscribed
and the message displayed above should
instruct the user to click on the bell
icon to do that
let's first create a button the message
that i want the button to read
is subscribe however this message gets
changed once the user clicks on the
button
so instead of explicitly mentioning
subscribe here
i create a prop i say sub
and i say subscribe here and back in my
render method
i say this dot state dot
sub so let's save it and if you look at
the browser now
you have a button which displays a
message subscribe now once the user
clicks on the button the message
displayed
should change to click on the bell icon
to never miss an update
so let's create an event handler for
that so here
button on click i call
another method and let's call the method
button change okay so this method should
update the state and change the message
and sub values to do that we make use of
a set state method
now a state can be updated in response
to event handlers
server responses or prop changes now all
the updation can be done using the set
state method now this is the general
syntax used by the method
we'll have a look at this further in the
demo now the set state method
conventionally
enqueues all the updates made to the
component state
and instructs react to re-render the
component and its children with the
updated state
now let's go back to our code editor and
look at the working
of this method now here i defined the
arrow function
button change if you are not familiar
with arrow functions i suggest you read
up on them
and this is the general syntax and here
i say
this dot set state and inside
i change my message to hit the bell icon
to never miss an update and my sub value
changes to subscribed let's save this
and now if you look at the browser when
we click on the subscribe button
the message changes to hit the bell icon
to never miss an update
so moving ahead let's use a bell icon so
that the user can click on it
once he clicks on the image the image
changes and a thank you message appears
on the screen
so for that i have two images i have
bell a
and bell b so i drag and drop both the
images
in my components folder all right
now let's import these images into our
new com.js file
here i say import bell a
from bell a dot png
and again i'll say import bell b
from bell b dot png
all right let me save it to display the
image on the screen
we make use of the image tag now this
tag has two attributes
one is the source attribute that
specifies the url and the other is the
alt attribute that specifies an
alternate text for the image
so here in my component i say i make use
of a paragraph tag
that will help display the image in the
next line
and then i use the image tag now since
my image changes once it's clicked
i have to define a property and pass the
event handler click
that will update the image so here
before specifying the source
let's go back to our state and define
another
property that is image url
and let's set it to bell a since that is
the image that i want to display first
let me save it and here in my image tag
i say source
equals this dot state
dot image url and then we have the alt
tag and i do not want to display any
message so i leave it as
it is now let's save it and if you look
at the browser
we have a bell displayed however now
let's change the dimensions of the bell
i do not want such a huge bell
so back in my vs code i define style
with width say 30 pixels
and a height with again 30 pixels let me
save this
and now if you look at the browser we
have a smaller icon
so once the user clicks on this image
the emit changes
and the message displayed here gets
updated to do that we'll have to define
an event
so let's go back to our vs code and here
in my image tag
let's say on click i define a method say
this dot image change
and now we define this method here
i see image change i make use of an
arrow function again
and again i use the set state method i
update the image
so i say image url is now set to bell
b and the message is updated
to thank you happy learning
so let's save this now and if we look at
the browser
we see the image and once clicked on it
the image gets updated and the message
changes
so finally let me refresh the browser
once and show the full execution
let me refresh following the
instructions let's click on the
subscribe button
and now it says hit the bell icon and
once i do that
the image updates and the message
changes alright
so with this we've come to the end of
the video i hope the concept of state is
clear to you
watch out for more videos on react.js
until then
keep learning and stay tuned to simply
learn
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel
and click here to watch similar videos
to nerd up and get certified
click here